50 en un demi siècle tout juste 7 et en
juillet 1954 aux etats unis une radio
diffusait le premier disque de rock n
roll enregistré par elvis presley cette
date marque la naissance officielle du
rock dans le monde
elvis n'était pas le seul il avait aussi
bill haley ou encore l'anglais vince est
là et des milliers d'autres qui allait
suivre olivier lozat grégory vasseur 8
juillet 50,4 la voie d'un inconnu passe
à la radio de naissance officielle du
rock
le premier enregistrement du jeune
prodige date d'un an plus tôt my
happiness
un disque enregistré pour 4 dollar
offert à sa mère
le premier chanteur atomique de la
nation et si l'un de ses biographes
reina
elvis presley est mort il ya 27 ans et
pourtant ces disques bat des records de
vente des compilations des reprises et
même désigné sans le chanteur de memphis
en fait en studio
seule la dernière piste était
commercialisé les trois quatre premières
étaient archivés
vu le succès que pose potentiellement
représente à lui seul jour d'hui la
maison disque périodiquement remet au à
la disposition du public s'est prise qui
avait été écarté à l'origine le king
mais rendons à césar ce qui revient à
bill haley lui n'a pas eu la chance de
passer immédiatement à la radio trois
mois avant et lui il nous offre le mode
d'emploi du rock
non
l'histoire s'accélère des jeunes fous
salamèche et au look rebelle
apparaissent l'anglais james taylor
ces chanteurs nous ont ouvert la voie
ils ont inventé vous avez tous les
gosses quand on a découvert la lys à
l'école c'est ce qui nous a donné le feu
les beatles
la bataille rangée entre les gamins de
liverpool et les stones ce le shaker
à
on nous a fait le coup du sexe de la
drogue des suicides
l'europe qui contre tous n'en veut
finalement à personne on l'a enterré
mille voix il est toujours vivant
éternel ambiguë